let's have a look at this next one cause
x equals this number here okay now
remember I asked you to write down the
base angle we're going to do it again
now when you're working out the base
angle this is probably worth jotting
down you don't need to worry about the
positive or negative
don't worry about plus or minus just
think about one enroute tooth now I
again have chosen this one because one
of the nice values does anyone remember
what nice angle goes with one on route
to 45 degrees and again if you can't
remember that that's no problem what
will I put into my calculator cos
inverse I'll write it down because it's
cause here right cos inverse of and
you're gonna have to use SERDES and
fractions and all that to get this okay
to find the base angle we don't have to
worry about the sign okay can you just
go ahead I want you to actually press
the buttons on there go shift cause put
in one on root 2 you should get 45 do
you get it can I have some nods yes not
going crazy good now what's the next
thing I had a look and I said is it
positive or negative in the answer is in
this case it's negative see that see the
negative so I'm gonna say cos x is
negative so now I ask the question again
which quadrants am I in okay now have a
look have a look carefully I'm just
going to go through one at a time it's
cause negative over here no cause it's
positive so I ignore that one is cause
negative over here it is cuz look it
doesn't appear in the list so I'm gonna
write two is cause negative in this
quadrant yes and then lastly what cause
it's positively that's why it says cause
so Shh stay with me because I know this
is tricky
what does 45 degrees
like in these two quadrants looks like
this X will be in quadrants you are
looking for obtuse angles right how did
I find my obtuse angle last time 180
minus that's 180 minus 45 yeah you check
here my arithmetic I'm pretty sure that
should be fine that's in the second
quadrant there's also a third quadrant
answer over here okay this is kind of
weird you don't have 180 minus that
you've got 180 plus that that sends you
down into this quadrant do you see that
okay you don't go up into the second
quadrant you go down to the third one
what side Renee D plus 45 225 okay so
just so we're all clear right once
you're in a quadrant you say first
quadrant that's just the base angle in
the second quadrant you go 180 degrees
take away the base angle I did that
again here 180 take away and then what
did I do for the third quadrant 180 plus
okay so yeah the final answer is this
and that's why I don't I don't write X
up here X is in fact not 45 if you go to
your calculator and you put in cause of
45 you don't get negative 100 - it
doesn't work you're supposed to get that
and you don't but if you try these guys
go ahead give it a go okay I'll actually
teach you a little trick when you when
you punch in this it gives you some
decimal right we actually did this last
time we just didn't use this application
what decimal does it give you - zero
point seven oh seven dot dot is that
right okay now I don't know what that is
because it's weird decimal stuff but we
use the trick before last time we
squared both sides do you remember that
if I square the left hand side your
calculators should now tell you I think
this will be a ha right aha
so if I went backwards it would be the
square root of that which is one over
two okay so there are your answers cause
135 cause 225 both are fun yeah okay so
because in each case I look at the base
angle you don't need the sign for that
and then I've got to work out what does
the base angle look like in each of
these quadrants and that's why you need
sign that's why you need the plus/minus
yep okay it depends on which quadrant
you're in so I'm gonna draw a nice
diagram to summarize all of this once
we're finished okay
why say last question can't we what
sorry okay if you type in cos inverse of
that you'll get what you go ahead see
what your calculator tells you okay now
I'm pretty sure it'll tell you this
answer here 135 right but it won't tell
you this one and then how do you find
this one and the answer is the both of
these answers actually come from this
guy right so we want to go to the root
of it and see what's going on underneath
okay okay now we've done this twice and
I have held your hand this time you're
gonna hold mine have a look we've been
using this pattern over and over again
what's the first thing I'm gonna write
down base angle how do I work out the
base angle tan inverse of that guy root
3 the square root of 3 okay it'll give
you a number what does your calculator
tell you 60 got it okay after I work out
the base angle now what okay before I
actually even answer the question I need
to know what question you're asking what
what's the next thing I say tan X is
positive thank you tan X I'm looking at
this thing and I'm looking for what sign
it is is it positive or negative
it's a plus or minus its plus so which
quadrants am I in now I'm gonna ask this
question uh yeah look let's see here
this one weights all right this one tan
is positive and which is the other one
three one and three okay
why is tan positive I'm getting it from
the very first line have a look see this
line here tan X is root 3 wall root 3 is
a positive number right whereas over
here see cos x is oh that's not positive
that's negative and that's why I wrote
this down in the same reason up here for
this angle sine X is 1/2 and 1/2 is a
positive number it's not negative so I
look back at the original line and
that's how I can tell or not if I had
rewritten a different question don't
write this
but it's just as easy to answer have a
look at this guy when I get to this next
step I will say 10x is negative so which
quadrants will I be in the the other
ones right does that make sense okay I
know my base angle I know which
quadrants I'm in so what do I do with
those in quadrant one
it's just 60 what about quadrant three
180 plus very good which is 240 and of
course you can double check by going to
your calculator trying out 1060 I think
it should give you one point seven three
whatever it is try 10 to 14 and you
should get the same outside okay
so this is all the bit tricky we're
doing a lot in our heads here so let me
help you out see this diagram here it's
like a quick and dirty version let's
draw a better one I need some space can
you draw for me a new Cartesian plane
and this will help you work out what to
do with your angles okay in the first
quadrant in the first quadrant when you
want to when you've got your base angle
what do base angles look like here they
just look like the base angle like if
your base angle is 60 then 60 is in the
first quadrant so that is fine but in
the second quadrant the base angle will
always be less than that it'll be from
naught to 90 so I'm gonna go a hundred
and eighty degrees takeaway okay
if you have a look at the different base
angles we got here 30 45 and 60 that's
convenient it's as if someone planned
this out you're always getting an acute
angle so 180 minus that acute angle will
always land you in the second quadrant
okay when I go to the third quadrant
okay
to get into the third quadrant you're
not going to go 180 - you're going to go
180 plus now we haven't got so far on
our review questions I haven't given you
anything that requires the fourth
quadrants so let me explain this one for
you fourth quadrant I'm going to try and
illustrate this with a bit of a fun
diagram okay you know how are in the
first quadrant where do we start
measuring from we start measuring from
this side here and then we go up there
we go anti-clockwise does that make
sense so it looks like that and that's
the little triangle that we create yeah
now in the second quadrant when you
think about 180 take away that where's
180 where where is 180 on here it's the
other two on the other side it's on the
negative so you're starting from here
and then you're going backwards because
it's - you see that so therefore you get
this kind of shape see there's this
symmetry here that is 180 and then I
take away so I'm going backwards back
around to where I started okay now when
I do 180 plus I'm starting from 180
again which direction am I going in I'm
going this has a name right this is 80
clockwise again like so so where would
you guess the fourth quadrant angle
should go where would it look I should
start from here and go down I should go
clockwise it sort of makes it all nice
and symmetrical right now how do I
actually state that this fourth quadrant
here we go it's not from naught it's not
from 180 or 180 again
it's from 360 right and then you take
away that base angle think about that
with all of these guys that we've just
done if your base angle with 30
what does 30 degrees look like in the
fourth quadrant
it'll be 360 take away 30 360 take away
30 years 3 30 which of course is over
here you've spun all the way around to
here what would 45 look like in the
fourth quadrant
it'll be 300 and 360 take away that's
315 degrees right and again you've
started from here you spun all the way
around and here you are in the fourth
quadrant and lastly this would be 300
okay